A.I. might be a human-destroying killer, but
without ANY A.I., the world wouldn't be a
very awesome place.
Stephen Hawking famously said to the BBC,
"The development of full artificial intelligence
could spell the end of the human race[1]."
Elon Musk has said it's like, "summoning the
demon[2]."
And yet, earlier this month, Elon Musk, Stephen
Hawking and important minds from around the
world signed an open letter from the Future
of Life Institute encouraging a future for
the technology.
The letter was widely interpreted by the media[3],[4]
to indicate these super-smart peeps are saying
A.I. is going to KILL US ALL, but that's not
entirely accurate.
It says, right in the open letter[5], "The
potential benefits are huge, since everything
that civilization has to offer is a product
of human intelligence," what they ARE saying
is how A.I. may change the way we live, work,
and affect the planet.
A.I. could solve problems in ways we can't
conceive, and if done right might create a
better world for us in the process!
Might, being the operative word here…
At the moment, A.I. isn't dangerous in itself
unless you're living in the realms of films
and television.
The open letter is some of the greatest humans
NOW wanting to make sure the A.I. of the FUTURE
will be programmed to concern human safety.
Musk donated 10 million dollars alone to safety
of A.I.[6] because he knows: computers are
dumb.
We have to teach them morality, ethics and
empathy, just like we train it to drive, speak,
move cargo or play piano.
We have to recognize, the humans PROGRAMMING
the A.I. have biases.
If we create a banking A.I. using current
lending data as data points, it might lend
more to white people than black people; because
of the racism of the people who "taught" the
computer!
It's all in how we program it[7].
This open letter acknowledges[8] that A.I.
is beneficial, and it it's a pledge to make
sure that's a priority in the future too.
Early A.I. work was mainly done by computer
scientists, but it's now interdisciplinary;
encompassing biology, medicine, law and ethics,
psychology and so on.
Researchers are saying A.I. should make the
world safer and pledging to that fact.
As of now, the most advanced artificial intelligences
are still pretty basic, working in areas like
language processing, photo and face recognition,
shipping and logistics, or in driverless cars.
To say these are "intelligent" isn't entirely
correct.
Though often A.I. do have some machine learning,
computers only know what we teach them.
For example, the brain of a driverless car
can take you to the store, but it can't shop
for groceries; the variables are completely
different.
As of 2013[9], the most advanced A.I. in the
world, according to Business Insider, was
ConceptNet4.
It was built by M.I.T. and had the intelligence
of a preschooler, it could explore a bit on
it's own, but mostly needed humans to input
information for it to learn.
They're now up to ConceptNet5.3, and it's
a free download[10]!
Sure, a full A.I. might be bad, but these
rudimentary A.I. are nothing but helpful and
should continue to be!
Stephen Hawking himself uses a computer with
type of A.I. to speak[11] called Assistive
Context Aware Toolkit (ACAT[12]).
It uses his previous writings and communication
to predict what he's going to want to say.
That doesn't sound too dangerous… and without
the A.I. being able to learn, it wouldn't
be much help.
Hawking couldn't even TELL us to watch out
for A.I. without A.I.!!
Hawking, Musk, and researchers from the largest
and smartest technology firms and universities
in the world aren't saying, "Run for your
lives!"
They're saying "Run the right algorithms!"
What do you think about Artificial Intelligence?
Would you
want it?